good morning it gets Tuesday in a
stunning turn of events I find myself in
an airport wardrobe change Act today's
video comes to you in for very special
parts heart 1 your tour and Couture
seems to be going well I wish I was
there but you know I I can't sing or
play an instrument so I would be kind of
irrelevant reviews of your tour so far
include that it was so fun that people
had the best time ever and that you are
a surprisingly competent musician which
analysis I have to say I agree with Hank
I mean back in 2007 when you released
your a love song for Helen Hunt I had no
idea that you could even play the guitar
let alone like write and sing and
watching that video my main feeling
wasn't like oh this is a great song or
anything although it was it was when did
Hank get a guitar so you have
nerdfighters if you're in any of these
cities go to Hanks tour part to Batman's
just a rich guy with an affinity for
bats
so Inc when I showed our two competing
shirt designs to Sarah she laughed for
like eight minutes and then finally said
why would anyone buy a shirt that says
Batman's just a rich guy with an
affinity for bats so yeah if I can't
even convert my wife I'm concerned about
my ability to win this contest but both
these shirts are available for pre-order
until April 25th and then they will
never be available again I mean unless
they are for some reason I don't know
the future is unpredictable part three
why we're in the airport so Hank Sarah
and I are on our way to attend a gala or
possibly a gala hold on according to the
dictionary both are acceptable it's like
gif and gifs oh we're going to a gala
gala the word so fancy they named it
twice
this gala gal is to celebrate the time
100 Time magazine's list of the 100 most
important people in the world Hank you
might remember that ridiculously last
year I was on that list this year I have
apparently declined an important so it
didn't make the list but I did snag an
invite to the party I can't tell you how
delighted I am to have declined in
significance Hank long may it continue
this should save me the embarrassment of
having to explain to other members at
the time 100 exactly why I was on the
list which happened a lot at last year's
gala gal Rand Paul or whatever would be
like who are you exactly and I would be
like oh I'm the guy who popularized the
phrase French the llama and he would be
like yeah that's not a thing this year I
don't have to do any of that stuff when
people ask who I am I'll just be like
I'm Rand Paul's date card for strange
marriages Hank your airport video about
strange marriages reminded me of a
strange marriage I just heard about or
at least a strange engagement so many
years ago Hank in 2008 the first
nerdfighter gathering in Europe that I
attended happened in Amsterdam there was
like 30 or 40 nerdfighters there it was
just kind of like a
party and after it had been going on for
about an hour a Dutch nerdfighter I knew
from her video series best wishes from
the Netherlands came up to me and she
was like can you introduce us to the
Belgian boys they have cute accents and
now seven years later one of those Dutch
girls now woman is marrying one of those
Belgian boys now man so congratulations
to them I love it when nerdfighter like
turns into nerdfighter love so Hank the
weirdest part is that any one of your
concerts in the next couple weeks like
nerdfighters could meet and fall in love
and seven years later get engaged okay
they just called my name for final
boarding call I okay I got like my tux
shoes and my backpack everything is
totally disorganized no but make it to
the plane I hope I make it to the plane
I made it Hank I'll see you Friday